[Music]
hey mr. wonderful here with a really
unique episode I've asked mr. wonderful
you know because we talk about
entrepreneurship so much in the journey
and the town the challenge of doing it I
thought we'd bring on someone who's
actually been on Shark Tank not once
twice
this guy's a crazy chicken even to talk
yourself on the shark tank twice is
impossible so he's done it and who knows
he might be the only person who can come
on three times he's got the energy I'll
let him introduce himself and then we're
gonna take a whole bunch of questions
from ask mr. wonderful viewers but we've
got an entrepreneur here extraordinaire
Aaron Kevin thank you so much the
problem so my name is Aaron Marino I
have the YouTube channel alpha M and
basically from this channel it allowed
me to start different verticals and
different businesses I think that at my
core I'm an entrepreneur it just
happened that my business that I wanted
to basically start from the age of 12
was a fitness center I knew at 12 years
old what I wanted to do for the rest of
my life you know everything leading up
to the point at which I actually opened
a fitness center that's what it was
about from 12 years old I wanted to help
people change their lives and you know
as as you know entrepreneurship is not a
straight line and it was it was the most
devastating thing that happened when I
had to end up shutting the business down
back in 2006 because poopoo happens well
it happens and it happened a lot I think
there there should have been an omen we
signed the lease to our facility on the
September 11th that was pretty much a
telltale sign of how everything was
going to unfold I think that's a very
important list for everybody listening
because just because you assume success
just because you have the energy just
because you have the desire doesn't mean
it's gonna happen for you in the first
time in fact I believe that
entrepreneurs that go through the sting
of failure are motivated in a very
special way afterwards and clearly in
your case that's been exactly what's
happened because there's been a lot of
[ __ ] hits you and somehow here we are
you very successful now which is I'm so
happy to have you on my channel because
I want to talk a little bit about that
journey but you actually have a unique
amount of aura and energy and that's the
that you've been on Shark Tank twice
because when you came on the first time
I thought you were a real dick I mean
the idea was so preposterous the idea
that you were gonna sell a style system
three hundred bucks I know but it D be
DS yeah and the whole idea was so crazy
but because your storytelling was so
compelling you actually got people
seriously considering and I nearly had
to go down the line the other sharks to
say look no one's given this guy any go
this is way too crazy but you are very
good at explaining why it might have
value to somebody and that's part of the
challenge of being an entrepreneur to be
able to explain your opportunity in a
very short concise period of time which
you were very good at but after that you
came back and which is remarkable and
let's talk about that experience what
was that like first of all being one I
think it's less than 1% ever get back
yeah Shark Tank is is is amazing and
it's a it's a shame that people don't
really understand like what really goes
into it they only see a small window of
what happens well here's a chance for
you to say it is brutal it is I mean and
the one thing that you're gonna notice
if I tell you this it sort of ruins it
you your mouth gets so dry when you're
out there because you're scared [ __ ]
you're scared shitless yeah and so
you're there and and and lights camera
action and there is no stop
there is no okay do that again it's like
go go go and and you get grilled and
that's what I was not expecting I was
not expecting even though I watched it
hundreds of times I was not expecting
the questions to be not only as direct
and and sort of cut through all the
[ __ ] like it was this is what it's
about you know and I wasn't prepared for
that even though I knew my numbers I was
prepared and so the first time was kind
of a disaster I was so excited to be on
and I knew that I was gonna they matter
what you guys said I knew that I was
going to sell a ton of style systems
afterwards and the night that Shark Tank
aired I had all my friends and family
there everybody's there and I'm sitting
there and I had my my computer out and I
was ready to see that in that that
dollar amount to start there
to ring and I sold one unit the night
that shark tank aired
like quickly which by the way is
probably the worst performance of any
product ever
in Shark Tank history because the ideas
sucked
that's why and I think I told you
because I am mr. wonderful I tell the
truth it shocked but you came back but
so the reality hit me in the face all
right this is not this is not working
and so there I was about a month later I
knew that I needed a lower pricepoint
product something that every guy needed
as you deal was 300 bucks right yeah 300
bucks crazy on you I sold one shut up
usually you made hundreds of dogs act I
did I made hundreds and so I was I was
dyeing my hair when inspiration struck
my youtube channel was all about helping
guys look and feel great and hair
products were one of those things where
I was passionate about and I loved and
so I thought you know I'm gonna start a
I'm gonna start a hair product business
and it's been sort of a wild ride ever
since the YouTube channel continues to
grow I came back on Shark Tank for the
hair product and nobody wanted to invest
in the product no because first of all
your premise was for men right yes which
is a brutally competitive space and
everybody's question was the same
what's your customer acquisition
strategy because you're competing with
some of the Giants on earth some of the
biggest companies on earth are in this
space and they're beating each other up
and here you are Aaron saying hey hey
I'm here for a second time on shark take
I've got another crazy idea please give
me some money but I got it I got to
defend myself for a second if anybody
else would have gone in the shark tank
if they'd if I didn't have the the
backing or the reason I was selling was
because of my youtube channel if I went
in there or a entrepreneur went in there
with the business that in two years made
a million dollars it does and and the
margins were great growing at a fast
rate everybody would have been throwing
money at him but because I had this
ladies have the future in front of us we
only had your second idea the first one
absolutely suck we all remembered that
and we're thinking why is this guy back
the reason you were back is you are
tremendously good television which is a
great message to everybody out there you
have such energy in such a Noren the
camera likes you so much that the
producer said one more time with feeling
from the sky because everybody know
sometimes the second time up at bat is
when you hit the homerun and so I did I
I got a deal with
Barbara but she didn't want to invest in
the in the hair product business because
she still thought it sucked no she
didn't think it'd suck she but she was
investing it in to your point she wanted
a piece of my my youtube channel now
this was she wanted to diversify her
risk is what she wanted cuz she didn't
she knew you were great but she didn't
know which one of your ideas was gonna
hit which is fair I'll speak for her I
would have done the same thing with you
in fact I would have been much tougher
but the point was that she was saying
look I know something's gonna work for
this guy because he's got such an
incredible amount of energy I don't know
what it's going to be and that's exactly
what happened so fast forward I didn't
end up taking the deal since then I've
been able to start a few other
businesses basically leveraging my my
ability to you know communicate and and
have a large following so which one's
actually worked the hair product
business worked it's what are the sales
of that thing right now this past year
Barbara you bozo you let that get away I
can't believe it shame on you
it's imagine that dog that piece of poop
was doing million dollars gotta get to
the numbers said that was what why not
I'm all about no that's not and so
that's that's that's not so I have other
businesses as well I don't want to go
into the numbers with all of them that's
a pretty good number that's a pretty
good number for a product that really
thought was gonna suck so then my
largest business is a skincare company
called Tish Hanley that is a men's
skincare subscription business I have a
advertising agency that I started as a
result of not being able to sell my I
didn't want to sell advertising to my
channel I wanted somebody else to do it
and so I hired my best friend from high
school Terry who is a car salesman and
amazing car salesman and from moment one
everything took off in terms of your
sponsorship just just teases what's the
big nut what are you doing sales this
year across all this stuff a lot like
just give me a number
I mean a la see see here's where here's
it listen a lot is can mean two dollars
it's more than one dollar that's a lot
or it can mean something stops in it
what do you guys what about you come on
because you're the one that got out of
the tail yeah and I want Barbara to hear
just hell yeah you know eight figures in
that and that and that more than ten
million more than ten million more than
twenty million more than we'll just get
let's just leave it there
wait Barbara Barbara Barbara I'm gonna
buy you a new baby
you can fly here right now to meet Aaron
again new broom for you Barbara right
over here you can supply she can fly in
a broom yeah you know what love Barbara
but up but no everything is great I'm
incredibly fortunate that I get to do
what I love everyday which is create
content and the fact that you know being
an entrepreneur and having that in my
DNA in my blood you know you never know
where opportunity and the you never know
which one is gonna work exactly and you
got to keep your eyes open because what
but that's why I'm glad we're here today
together cuz we've got I get thousands
of questions from entrepreneurs that
we're actually at the beginning of your
journey maybe they failed once maybe
they haven't even started yet that's why
I want to tap into you today on these
ask mr. wonderful questions I got a
bunch of them here let's listen and then
I want us both to answer them from the
different perspectives we have because
you have come out of a hole you have a
little story on this watch before we see
ya right
this is a beautiful Rolex you know I'm a
watch collector I really appreciate that
it's a gorgeous rose gold piece but it's
got an inscription on the back of it
what does it say yeah most people it's
funny most people celebrate victories or
wins or benchmarks in their business by
by buying nice watches or they'll buy a
watch to represent some some zeal that's
what I do that's what I do something
good at a celebration of success
I bought this watch when things were bad
in terms of and and bad is relative
because that's not a cheap piece no but
I I had my eye on it and I was going
through sort of a low point in terms of
emotionally you know things with YouTube
weren't going in the direction that I
wanted but I bought it to remind myself
that as long as I keep trying as long as
I don't stop it'll get better and I can
do this and so on the back I had
inscribed get to work and so everybody
told me all that these values get to
work those get to work figure it out
initially I would have said that
would've devalue to watch except since
then maybe that watch is your lucky
timepiece
because look what's happened to you you
look at it every day and you remind
yourself what you put on the back of
that at your low point I love that story
watches are about conversations we just
had one so that's a very successful
piece for you because every time someone
looks at it says well I really like that
watch you can tell them the story of
that absolutely that's great I love it
I love that too that's great let's get
to some questions okay because we're
gonna have some fun here I mean I love
the fact that you can relate and I've
not listened to these questions so
they're men either
so we're ready let's go at a fashion
tech startup that uses AI to automate
the fashion photography process here in
New York City a finished college with
more debt than originally planned around
21,000 yeah I want to save and invest
for the future so I can start my own
business one day I believe I need to
eliminate all my debt before saving and
investing and of course eventually
starting my own business do you
recommend someone in my pitch in my
position to focus all their extra money
your savings and commissions towards my
student debt or is it advantageous to do
a little bit of both saving and invest
as well as pay off the debt even if
it'll take more time thanks mr.
wonderful
I've always resonated with your story
growing up as an expat with you and
myself I love your videos
any advice would be great thanks you
know what's cool about this question
it's in your space it's in fashion a
little bit yeah but the guy is $21,000
in the hole
he hasn't even brought any revenue in
doesn't have a business yet what do you
tell so for me I think it really depends
on for one interest rate on that on that
on that student level at 7% 7% I would
probably not wait to start saving for
both my my future in terms of my
business it sounds like he's an
entrepreneur he has an idea that he
wants to go after I would pay down the
debt but I think that I would be
utilizing my funds to try to start that
business that I that I ultimately feel
will propel me towards success but you
know so that freaks you out is what
you're saying I I don't have any debt
once I had to file bankruptcy so you you
felt I felt felt that the terror of that
there's nothing there
nothing that takes the fun out of life
like debt and not knowing how you're
gonna pay your well said and and for me
when I had my fitness center and it was
failing I was taking money off of my
credit cards to pay my staff I mean it
was bad and at that point I had to dry I
was driving a beer cart to put gas in my
car at a country club and Here I am a
thirty year old guy who has a business
at a fitness center that I was trying to
franchise and I'm driving a beer cart
and the worst part about it Kevin I
didn't have a plan B I'm the type of
entrepreneur that I don't have a safety
net
I'm plan a all the time direct and when
that exploded I know a [ __ ] idea what
I was gonna do and that was the scariest
part for me so I totally agree with you
in that I share I have no debt zero and
every time my credit card comes in every
month every cent is paid off because I
live in fear of debt I've been through
that too
I didn't get to bankruptcy but I got
very close and it scared the living [ __ ]
out of me and it made me feel unhealthy
it puts so much stress on you so I think
both of us giving the same advice number
one focus is paid on the twenty one
thousand dollars but don't give up your
dream you have an interesting idea of
fashion using AI I love entrepreneurs
with disruptive ideas he's got one but
that debt thing is a real message in
that question and and so too you know
that's for everybody with college debt
it's between six to seven percent most
of these loans they kick up to that rate
pretty damn fast and you've got to start
focusing but whatever you're doing take
20% 10% and pay it down there's also but
there's something also exciting about
that because he's in this new space and
so you know there's with startups
there's there is that entrepreneurial
spirit and so you know that there
there's also the idea that if this hits
it could hit big but there's also a
tremendous amount of risk you know
exactly the risk with a start-up or
something that's unproven you know
everybody's looking for that exit and I
really think that with certain
businesses you really just need to be
smart and disciplined with the way that
you spend your money and not think that
and not assume that it's going to hit
super big and so just be careful pay
your debt down because being debt free
is the most liberating feeling you'll
ever have
well-said let's get another question
here I'm sorry am I am I talking more
than you know
cool then I love the fact that we're
doing this together because at the end
of the day you've lived that ride you've
gone through it and so this is great
advice let's listen to this one again
I've never heard these questions so I
love the fact that just cold turkey
hey mr. wonderful Joe here you expand
your my favorite shark I was just
wondering what you do when the woman you
love will never love you back
thanks mr. wonderful whoa Joe baby yeah
this is a good question great question
you know I'll tell you something in life
when you fall in love with somebody and
they don't return that that can be a bad
affliction because it really drags your
energy down but at some point you have
to be honest with yourself particularly
when you have that conversation with
them say look is there any chance
between the two of us all of us have
been there people try and say oh it's
never happened to me [ __ ] it happens
to everybody but that makes you realize
they're not your partner they're not
there for you they don't love you back
and that's just the nature of love it's
a [ __ ] that way but you have to have
that conversation with them this is my
advice to Joe and say look I really have
some strong feelings for you but if you
if you can never reciprocate that this
is a Bonnie Raitt song by the way
it's a classic which you professors are
loved to somebody and they're never
gonna love her back broke her heart what
do you do Joe my advice to you is you
got to be honest the fact is you are
amazing right you're an incredible guy
and you're gonna make some woman the
luckiest woman ever but one of the
issues that we fall into as men is that
we do get sort of tied in and
preoccupied with that one person right
and really it's because of something
that we can't have right the truth is
you need to read the writing on the wall
and and it's time for you to take care
of yourself and understand that you're
never going to find that perfect person
that's out there for you until you are
able to shut the door on on this this
person that that obviously is not worthy
of your love and affection you think as
you get a little older Aaron that you
understand the pitfalls of love and you
start to realize I don't want to drag
myself maybe you maybe you become more
of an oyster you protect your emotions
because they know how much it hurts but
if you've never been hurt you can never
really fall in love absolutely that's
the issue that's the issue so I think
for Joe you got to write this one off
and you got to move on aaron has the
right advice there there's
always another fish in the ocean
somewhere by the way she really smoking
hot that's breaking your heart I'll
never meet someone that hot you will
absolutely it's you will that's a great
question is it founder is it really a
cofounders no it isn't it's a partner
she's talking about but I mean here's
the real debate that I've learned you
know you're really good at some things
and not good at others every
entrepreneur is exactly that way so I'm
a good sales marketing person I hate
logistics in manufacturing bores the
[ __ ] out of me but without that skillset
I can't really scale so along the way in
my businesses I've always found someone
who can make up for my weaknesses and
I've made them partners by giving them
equity they're not really co-founders as
you've said but in order for them to
stick through the hard times and really
suffer the pains the slings and arrows
of building a business you got to give
them a piece of the action that's the
way I look at it so if you are actually
growing and it's working and you realize
you have weaknesses you've got to find
someone else to fill those holes now
maybe you can find a point employees
we're gonna have to pay them a lot I
prefer to have people with skin in the
game
soldiers beside me we're all fighting
the same war together and we're in for
the mission and we all get the upside so
I think if you're asking me this
question right now and I'm dying to hear
what erin has to say I think you're
ready for a partner but make sure you're
not greedy don't be a greedy Pig pigs
got slaughtered if you're if you're
giving away equity make sure it's the
right person take a long time to make
that decision but together you'll make a
much bigger pie and that equity will be
worth a lot to both of you what do you
say the one thing I would say I have
some businesses that I partners in some
businesses that I don't and there are
upsides to both both scenarios the one
thing I would say whenever you are
considering adding somebody to the team
to something that you're building your
baby you want to make sure that it's not
only the right fit now but it's the
right fit moving forward and what I mean
by that is I think too often people are
thinking I need to give away too much
too soon and they think it's you know it
has the best like immediately I would
say that in this scenario find somebody
that is going to add value that's going
to fulfill or fill the voids in which
you know you're not good at and and then
do it over time do it gradually there's
nothing wrong with seeing how this
person performs because the worst
scenario give them the equity as they as
they perform have it best over two years
a year give them you know certain a
little bit of equity
you know after year one your to have
different benchmarks and really because
everybody's gonna sell you how great
they are everybody is going to tell you
you I'm amazing I can do this
I can do that but the truth is it's put
up or shut up and in business you know
talk is cheap you've got to actually
execute and and you've got to make sure
that the person that has told you how
excellent they are at executing is
actually able to do it and help your
business move forward and if it's not
well then that's like you're you're cool
with giving a piece of the pie oh
absolutely you see the merit in doing it
oh 100% - but I like your strategy if
you if you layer it in that's fine but
by that time it may be more employees or
maybe more people that have to share and
that's what options generally companies
put about 15 percent of their equity
into people that are coming on to grow
it you love to have that problem if
you're actually giving away equity
because you need more help that means
you're growing that's a wonderful
outcome I wish them good luck on that
one it's very cool all right let's go to
the next one
I'm having so much fun with this there
we go
they're going hi mr. wonderful my name
is Tara and I was wondering if you could
give me will me and my husband a little
bit of advice on dressing for job
interviews we were both actually
interviewing at new companies this month
and neither of us have been in the job
interview game for
we five years or more I've heard that
wearing a suit and tie or a blazer and
heels for a woman used to be the way to
go but that some new companies can think
that you're stuffy or will fit the job
culture yeah we would love your advice
is it better to over dress or is it
better to be cool and approachable
you're always fashionable and you've
talked a lot about dressing for your job
before so we would love to get your
advice thank you well Tara you've come
to the right place I have the
fashionista man beside me here Aaron I'm
gonna let you take a stab at this sure
she's raising a really good question for
both men and way they're back in the job
market they want to look sharp they want
to win the job basically I think the
first thing you need to do is do your
research figure out what the corporate
culture is like at the the place that
you're actually applying for because one
of the issues if you're going to like a
cool like tech startup I really feel
like it does to some degree depend on
the the the business that you're
actually going and applying for and so
do your research if it's a cool tech
startup in the valley what are you
saying you're gonna be a little hipper
in terms of what clothing your weight a
little more free you don't have the
pressure to dress it might not require a
suit and tie something super
professional it might be a business
casual or a business casual type of
environment but I always would say err
on the side of overdressing versus under
dressing 100% of the time that is your
one shot and your employer knows that it
doesn't get any better than right now
like this is the best if you are going
in for an interview you know that if
this person didn't shave if you know
this person didn't you know didn't wear
pantyhose or whatever the situation is
it's never getting any better and so I
would say that you if you want to dress
and be cool and hip later that's fine
that's for HR to work out but right now
you need to be respectful of the
position you're going after but also do
your due diligence in identifying what
the corporate culture is because if you
go in in a three-piece suit and it
doesn't require that you may be over
dressing for the potential job or
interview it's a great answer I'm gonna
take a stab at it too because I actually
interview
a lot of people and and I've learned
that the keywords you just brought up
there and you only get first time to do
a first impression only once that only
happens once when you walk in that room
and you look at each other so clothing
is really interesting because it's
different for men and women men have
fewer choices particularly if you're
going for a job in financial services
what's happened on both the east and the
west coast over the last five years is
the tie has come back as a sign of
respect that you care if you're in the
financial services you're in an industry
of trust and the Styles have become very
very clean and the tie and also you know
that the the colors have become more
muted it's very interesting to watch
that happen it happens in San Francisco
Los Angeles I see it in New York Miami
Chicago and I travel all those cities
people are looking crisp clean and
subtle for them for the sight of men now
women this is very controversial because
if you look at some of the codes that
are now written by large corporations
about women's clothing they're putting
in the concept of not showing too much
chest
they don't want controversial dressing
they don't want it to be flirtatious
because of all the meat to things that
are going on in the world and they're
trying to tone down and believe me in
big companies people meet each other and
stuff happens that's just men and women
doing their thing but how you clothe of
its caught if you close yourself in a
controversial way that's gonna hurt you
in a job interview
are they risking something that's the
employer saying themselves and they make
notes about this stuff I can guarantee
you and very often they're asking for a
picture of you before you show up just
so they can see what you're wearing
women have to be very careful that they
look professional that's what matters
whatever that means to you taking into
account your idea about the company
you're going to work in but if you come
in with anything controversial that
hurts and that's why their dress coats
and that's why companies as they grow
just passed 25 people
HR starts to put in place dress codes
because they don't want to cause tension
in the workplace great question though I
loved it never had one like that before
and good it came when you are on the set
because you're the fast and ista guy you
keep telling me that you're
overestimating my ability come on I told
him he is twice on Shark Tank remember
all right
[Music]
from Colombia at the moment my question
is if it is better to grow slowly or
seek funds to grow faster we're spending
over a million dollars a year wide open
for two years only thank you a million
bucks in three stands the kid knows what
he's doing you gonna live off that
you're good you're probably making about
30% margin on product like that I would
think you know bringing in 300,000 maybe
it's speak to you 200 300 thousand I'm
gonna give him that if he's running it
so that's a good question you first you
go out you borrow money to expand or you
just grow slow and steady
so here's the thing that you got to
figure out if you raise money how are
you going to use that money in order to
take your business to that next level
one of the big mistakes that I see a lot
of entrepreneurs and businesses get into
is they take money because they think
hey I need more money but they don't
know how they're going to spend it in
order to actually generate more revenue
I am a firm believer that you never you
know it sort of goes back to the whole
debt thing I don't want that on my
personal life I don't want that in my
business unless I know if I can use and
you've said this all the time I just
want to add fuel to the fire right or or
cash to the fire make it burn gasoline
to the fats what it is and so unless you
know how you're going to spend that
money and you've got the the
infrastructure in place in order to be
able to scale your business bigger
stronger more profitable based on you
taking money I say until you know how
you're going to do that until you have a
roadmap of I'm gonna spend X I'm gonna
get this back don't take the money do
not fall into the trap because if you
take money from friends and family
they'll let it slide but once you go
into that institutional money then
they're calling you then they're like
hey why aren't you selling 27 more
burgers a day and do you want to answer
to those people that's my question to
you I think it's a great question
because clearly they figured out the
model 3 stands doing a million bucks I'm
gonna say that they're probably making
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
pre-tax on that it could be a pretty
good margin business you're selling
direct to the customer cash so you don't
have a lot of credit you have to worry
or bad loans or anything else what I
would do is I would open one more stand
using the cash flow of the other three
in a very close geography in other words
just make it a place that you can
actually go visit every day
I love businesses that spin cash and you
can live off
I hate debt so I it's it's just what
happens is you have to start hiring
people relying on them to have the same
fire you have that maintain these stand
sounds like a bit of a family business
which i think is terrific you don't have
to become McDonald's to have a
successful business so I would cool it
I'd open one more with the cash you've
got then one after that grow it slowly
zero debt that's for other people not
you my friend but a great question great
answer yeah great answer Kevin it's like
you've done this before yeah well I hate
that just like you do okay here we go
one more time with feeling earn I'm here
Hank that's a simple question right
saying no to Aaron that was my biggest
steal and it was a huge mistake the guys
walking around with maybe 20 million in
sales it's more barbers problem she's
the one that missed it
the largest deal in Shark Tank history
actually is mine it's the the company
called plated and is measured by the
biggest axe said it was three hundred
million dollars
they came on Shark Tank did not get a
deal they were asking for such a
ridiculous valuation two guys just like
you we ran in from a year later in the
streets of New York they talked they
told me where they were at and they said
look we'd love to get a shark into the
deal and I then did the deal a year
afterwards and that was sold only 24
months after that to Albertsons for
three hundred million dollars so they
had nothing when they came on Shark Tank
that's the biggest acts that we've seen
so far in Shark Tank history but it just
shows you the dream is alive you can
come on shark tank
with a great idea you know get an
investment for a shark and together we
can use the platform to blow it up big
there's been so many cases of that and
great entrepreneurs show up every day
and you know all joking aside Aaron's
probably one of the best examples of
what it takes to get on Shark Tank you
need energy you need you need to show
that you really care and are passionate
about the business as he was and he got
on twice now barber screwed up that's
her problem
you know I'm gonna get Barbara to new
brooms this you go east west that's how
it'll work listen it's been great with
you today Thanks amazing thank you this
is one of the best episodes so far I've
asked mr. wonderful until next time keep
dreaming big that's what it takes
thank you so much Aaron thank you Kevin
good luck guys you can do it
[Music]